Uh,
before the beginning of my introduction
of our first speaker,
I think I'd be remiss not to mention my
observation from the floor and that is
there is an overwhelming number of young
faces in the crowd.
And considering that this is a Sunday,
this is your time off from studies or
work for you to come out here to hear us
talk about freedom of speech and
political correctness.
Uh,
to me is an indication that there is a,
a zeitgeisty among millennials among
young people right now.
And I know we've got disciples of Pha
and,
and orwell and Huxley,
a Bronc crowder,
myself as a somewhat young Haig Alien,
I can't help but think that,
um,
dialectics is real.
Uh,
the,
the main stream media,
the academic pulpit.
Um,
what we've been fed,
um,
as the thesis,
we're now pushing back and there was a
new anti thesis that is forming and God
willing,
I'm the synthesis that comes out of it,
errs on the side of freedom,
not social justice,
truth and not political correctness.
Our next,
our first distinguished guests is a man
who introduced neuroplasticity to the
world.
The idea that our brains are not rigidly
hardwired as was once believed,
but that they can change and indeed be
rewired.
Dr. Norman Doidge is a Canadian born
psychiatrist psychoanalyst and a world
famous professor on the faculties of
both the University of Toronto,
Toronto and Columbia University in New
York,
Dr which began as an award winning poet
and student of literature,
literary classics and Philosophy at the
University of Toronto.
He obtained his medical degree at the
University of Toronto,
then moved to New York where he's had a
residency in psychiatry and obtained a
degree in psychoanalysis at Columbia's
University,
Department of Psychiatry and Columbia
University Center for psychoanalytical
training and research.
This was followed by a two year Columbia
University Slash National Institute,
Pardon me,
Institute of Mental Health Research
Fellowship where he was trained in
empirical science techniques.
Dr Deutsch has written over 170
scientific and popular articles as well
as he appearing on several television
programs and various documentaries.
His New York Times internationally
bestselling mind bending book.
The brain that changes itself with over
1 million copies sold,
describes how the principle of healing
the plastic brain is becoming
established in fact in laboratories
through a greater understanding of the
ways in which circuits of neurons
function and are created by thought aunt
Dr Georges.
More recently published book,
the brain's way of healing presents
astounding discoveries in the brain's
healing power.
He is persuasive and curious as a
writer,
a rigorous thinker while the subjects on
which he writes or at the very edge of
our current understanding of the mind
and body.
Please join me in welcoming Dr. Norman
Doidge.
Thank you very much.
Can you all hear me?
Thank you faith
and thank you joffrey and thank all of
you for coming to this talk,
which is a shows,
a kind of civic mindedness and reaching
beyond oneself.
Okay.
I'm going to approach this subject from
a particular vantage point which links
up some things that are I think are very
important in classic political
philosophy and but we know about
psychology and the brain,
so I'm going to call it the infallible
state of mind.
And this is George Eliot,
perhaps the most philosophical of,
of novelis in way.
Um,
and in middle march,
her masterpiece or one of her
masterpieces,
there's this,
and this is the epigraph in a way for my
talk,
her anger said as anger is apt to say
that God was with her,
that all heaven must be on her side.
So you can think about that as the talk
goes on.
The problem we face today is really a
very simple one.
In an open society,
people are different and so we have
disagreements about important matters.
How do we sort through these
disagreements and even perhaps benefit
from the different points of view,
but also avoid splitting apart into
warring factions or violence in the
process.
These are the topics today that I'm
going to discuss.
First our freedom of speech and
political correctness mutually
exclusive.
Then I'm going to present the classical
liberal argument for freedom of speech.
It's not just because I want to speak,
that I ought to be allowed to speak,
and why free speech,
liberal democracy and individual liberty
are inseparable.
Why you can't really have one without
the other.
I'm going to discuss why robust freedom
of speech is the best protection that
exists for minorities and for marginal
groups,
and how the practice of political
correctness intentionally undermines
freedom of speech and unintentionally
undermines many of its own stated goals.
And then finally,
I'm going to weave into this my
understanding of the infallible frame of
mind that feels so confident in shutting
down others.
So our freedom of speech and political
correctness mutually exclusive,
this is our world.
And then you'll notice that the free
countries are in green and the purple
ones are authoritarian or a towel.
Terrian regimes and the yellow ones are
somewhat in the middle,
partly free.
And the first thing that strikes one is
that most of the green is kind of to the
west.
And the exceptions to that,
countries like Israel,
India,
Australia,
even South Africa have had some impact.
Um,
from have been influenced to some
extent,
often in a major way,
often as a colony,
um,
are dominated by the British.
And many of these ideas about freedom of
speech come from the British tradition.
You'll also notice that there these are
huge landmass is,
and they,
they seem almost equal in the countries
that are are purple.
There's very limited equality of rights
for women,
for gays,
um,
for various religious minorities.
Those rights exist in the countries that
agree.
So it looks like it's kind of 50,
50 freedom versus authoritarianism.
But actually if you look at this by
population,
only 9.9% of us live in democracies.
That's kind of shocking.
The rest of us live in highly flawed
democracies with limited rights or
hybrid regimes and 34%,
so three and a half times live in
authoritarian regimes.
So democracy is not in fantastic shape.
If you look at things in terms of
population and ideas like freedom of
speech,
um,
if they're only really substantiated,
9.9% of people on the planet arguably
are an endangered species or the at
least can't be taken for granted.
And that's one of the reasons I'm here
today.
But why discuss this in the West?
In a way we have more freedom of speech
than ever before with the Internet.
Anyone can publish a blog,
can set up their own media company,
develop social media websites,
and in some respects the taste for
freedom of expression is rising.
And yet that same electronic media has
made it possible for everyone to monitor
everyone,
for your boss,
to monitor you,
for your government monitor to you.
And so suddenly the temptation of
blocking expression is also,
um,
something to be taken very seriously.
Some recent examples of political
correctness.
So President Obama responding to the
rise of political correctness on campus
gave a speech in Iowa in September,
2015 in a way,
you might argue that he articulated in a
colloquial way the basic liberal
argument,
a liberal,
I mean the classical liberal argument
for liberty and freedom of speech.
The purpose of college is to create a
space where a lot of ideas are present.
He said and collide.
When I went to college,
suddenly there were some folks who
didn't think at all like me and if I had
an opinion about something,
they'd look at me and they'd say,
well that's stupid.
And then they describe how they saw the
world and they might have had a
different sense of politics or they
might have a different view about
poverty or they might have a different
perspective on race.
And sometimes their views would be
infuriating to me.
But it was because there was this space
where you could interact with people who
didn't agree with you that I then
started testing my own assumptions and
sometimes I realized,
you know what?
Maybe I've been too narrow minded.
Maybe I didn't take this into account.
Maybe I should see this person's
perspective.
So that's what college in part is all
about.
And here's him going on.
Just after that,
I was just talking to a friend of mine
about this.
You know,
I,
I've,
I've heard some college campuses where
they don't want to have a guest speaker
who,
you know,
is too conservative or they don't want
to read a book if it has language that
is offensive to African Americans or
somehow sends a demeaning signal towards
women.
And you know,
I,
I gotta tell you I don't agree with that
either.
I don't agree that you,
when you become students at colleges
have to be coddled and protected from
different points of view.
It all,
I think that you should be able to
get off
use.
You should invite anybody,
anybody who comes to speak to you and
you disagree with,
you should have an argument with them,
but you shouldn't silence them by saying
you can't come because you know my
senses.
I'm too sensitive to hear what you have
to say.
Um,
that's not,
that's not the way we learn either.
So what do you think?
All right.
Amen.
He said Amen.
All right.
Okay.
Now the president used the words coddled
and protected and not listening to
people because we are too sensitive to
hear what you have to say.
And coddling and overprotecting it might
seem,
would produce non resilient passive
people,
but coddling can also cause people to
become self focused in title and
disrespectful of others.
In other words,
silencing gathers is not always a very
pretty thing.
So there was the Yale Halloween crisis,
um,
and some Yale students complained to the
administration that it was offering very
heavy handed advice,
telling them that they would be
insensitive to wear costumes that
symbolize cultural appropriation.
At that point,
Erika Christakis,
who was a Yale lecturer and a specialist
in childhood education and who had with
her husband been involved in supervising
one of the residences at Yale.
She wrote an email encouraging students
to stand up for their own right to
decide what to wear and not cede control
to others to make moral decisions for
them.
And she said,
if you object to others,
costumes speak up.
By all means.
Now a faction of students then demanded
that the Christakis is be fired.
Nope.
One of the things that was happening is
there were groups at Yale saying that
they felt there was not enough respect
for,
um,
cultural diversity,
uh,
along lines of race and so on.
But this was the event,
the,
uh,
Erika Christakis email that triggered
things after she wrote that email,
her husband,
Nicholas
tweeted,
President Obama saying the things I just
showed you saying,
you know,
we shouldn't try to overprotect
students.
And then in this very widely viewed
video,
one young woman,
and then I'm going to show you more,
came up to,
um,
Nicholas Christakis with about a hundred
other students at a protest,
um,
to speak to him.
And I used the word speak in quotation
marks while you watched this,
try to analyze what's happening here.
The exception is because other people
have rights to not just what
you understand
that
your job please comfort and home for the
students.
So I have not done that by sending out
that email that goes against your
position.
Do you understand that
I have a different vision if that is
what you think about being
here,
you are doing that.
They're going to leave.
They're going to transfer because you
are up ports,
not sleep at night.
We're out.
We out are just stop thing.
Okay.
Um,
so amongst the thing she said is you are
not to create an intellectual space
here.
Um,
this should be a safe haven.
It should be a home.
Um,
and where the function of college goats,
it's hard to say,
but one might argue this is just one
person who had a bad day and was,
was,
was very upset,
but it wasn't just one person.
Oops,
sorry.
It went on and for quite a while
do even for causing pain.
I was looking for the right word.
Hello.
[inaudible] violence.
I can disagree with that statement.
What is your name?
You need to bend down.
I'm not bending.
What's her name?
I do not want you to take your,
okay.
I do not want,
I do not respect you.
I'm going to hear that.
I'm looking at this smirk in your face
like I'm disgusting
and I'm sick watching them argue with
you.
We've been standing on stage literally
for at least five to six hours between
you and Halloween,
which wean last night.
To now.
We've been arguing with people who are
not willing to be listened to for a long
time and all I see from you is arrogance
and ego.
I am thick looking at you.
I am disgusted watching,
argue with you.
You are not listening.
You are disgusting.
I don't think you understand that.
And I,
before I wasn't I before,
I was not angry per say.
I was disappointed.
Maybe I thought maybe there was real
important before apology.
You've clearly told us that you did not
plant.
Offer an apology for your words.
You left the meeting last night to go
home and vent.
Tweak.
Do not interrupt me to tweet from your
twitter and then the filaments.
Twitter,
you showed no remorse.
You tried to let your wife leave that
conversation without having answered for
herself.
That is disgusting.
That is sick.
And now I wasn't angry before.
I was not angry before,
but now I am actually angry sir.
I really do not interrupt me.
I was not angry and now I want your job
to be taken from you.
I don't want them to have this job.
I am discussing knowing that she worked
at Yale University where I will get my
degree.
I will look back and think,
I have to argue with you.
Yeah.
Halloween problem had to do with
cultural appropriation.
Some people would be dressing up as
different different groups,
cultural appropriations about who can
say what.
In 2015 the University of Ottawa Student
Federation canceled a Free Yoga Class,
had been going on for about eight years.
It was taught at the center for students
with disabilities.
It was free again,
I say that and it was closed down
because some students were uncomfortable
with the cultural issues involved and
when asked for explanations that had to
do with the fact that yoga was from
India and the instructor was not from
India and so she had no right to teach
it and it wasn't even clear that people
in the West had the right to teach yoga
to others.
So there were,
there was no right to offer.
Offer that.
Let's talk about fiction.
The PC issue about fiction is who can
write what.
It's argued that a person of one
religion,
race or gender cannot create a fiction
character of uh,
who is another religion or race or
gender.
It's cultural appropriation,
it's identity theft.
But why?
I would say stop it writing.
Why following that reasoning should
anyone be permitted to read fiction,
which involves recreating characters who
are different from ourselves in our
heads.
This problem is important because
reading fiction as doctors Raymond Mark,
he felt Lee and Professor Peterson here
today have shown actually increases
empathy for readers.
If we wrote the kind of fiction demanded
the art form would disappear and be
replaced by add nine memoir.
Me Talking about myself and I would add
to myself probably wouldn't be very
interesting.
So political correctness is not just
about correct action,
but correct thought and seeks to limit
the imagination.
Okay,
so forgive me for quoting a novelist.
Um,
therefore,
but censorship is rarely self limiting.
This is from Saul bellow's,
Augie March 1st page.
Everyone knows there is no firmness or
accuracy of suppression.
If you hold down one thing,
you hold down the adjoining.
If there's an idea that's forbidden,
there's something similar to it.
Or connected to it.
That's arguably forbidden.
And so it's a kind of a hunt of,
it's a kind of exercise of scrupulosity
that is not self limiting.
Okay.
People have tried to understand what's
going on here.
I mean,
President Obama picked it up.
There's a kind of hypersensitive
sensitivity afoot and this first showed
itself in the 1990s and late 1980s and
Camille Paglia,
the independently minded feminist
thinker art historian,
a student of literature,
wrote an article called the Nerc nursery
school campus.
She wondered what's new here.
She noted and has noted since the hyper
protective helicopter parenting,
it seems to undermine resilience and
independence over protected.
People will turn to adults or the legal
system to protect them,
encouraging authorities to regulate the
sensor,
others around them and perhaps
encouraging them to,
as we saw with the Halloween costumes
censor themselves.
This is so different from the 60s where
students were seeking freedom.
There are new,
smaller one to two children families,
which encourage a feeling in the child
that the world of adults revolves around
the child.
Compare that to families 150 years ago
or families in Quebec.
You know 70 years ago where you have
five to 10 children and you're raised by
your siblings.
They don't buy that bullshit.
They don't think you're so special.
Okay.
Then there are the dean natured urban
upbringings,
people with limited experience in
nature,
farming rural life where self reliance
as a key virtue think that most of
life's upbringing,
stem,
not from nature but societal ills,
human decisions about how to distribute
goods,
awards and status and how about the zero
tolerance policies in schools incur,
they encourage and moderation and they
encourage ignoring context of,
of difficulties that they're assessing.
Political correctness as a term of
evolved out of the Russian revolution
comes from Russian.
It was used by the land in this left to
describe keeping to the party line or
the spirit of the party party most and
lending himself wrote a number of
articles about the importance of holding
collect correct political views.
So there would be the baits and some
people would differ about certain
things,
but certain views were not politically
correct.
They didn't go with doctor.
Now pc was then used by the left.
Later on with conscious irony is like as
a kind of installed to describe someone
on the left who had too much fervor
toeing the party line.
So there there are tendency to Dogma and
doctrine was so intense that it ups it,
it obscured their own humanity.
So that ironic use of pc and not as a
compliment was became mainstream in the
1990s to more or less described the
techniques and attitudes designed to
influence um,
society to tow the party line of the
liberal portion of the left.
Not all of the left is a liberal.
So these are the techniques that are
familiar to all of us to attack freedom
of speech or expression or invalidate
speakers and shut them down.
We have speech codes that determine what
people can't,
they prescribe or forbid we have forced
speech which mandates what people must
say it prescribes and puts words in
people's mouth.
We have dress codes isn't the Halloween
situation or other,
other,
other examples.
Non platforming the term not giving a
person a platform which was I understand
originally used in Britain to describe
not giving violent fascists a platform.
And then it was very quickly applied to
not giving anyone from Israel a
platform.
And then it generalized to not giving a
platform to people we disagree with.
You can boycott lectures,
you can block entrances to lectures,
you can drown out lecturers with noise
machines,
shouting fire alarms,
Professor Peterson's experienced much of
this.
And you can pour fallow human substances
on people if that's your thing.
And then you can get a huge,
oh,
you can organize to forbid institutional
invitations.
So the bds movement to shut out all the
attempt to shut out all was rarely
academics from having a right to speak,
mostly in Europe and North America would
be an example of that.
And then Internet flash mobs,
petitions,
I mean,
it's pretty hard not to get a petition
of 20,000 people objecting to something
or someone,
it's so easy.
Anonymous character assassination,
Internet misinformation.
So at to the pro free speech rally at
the University of Toronto,
someone costed Professor Peterson and
said,
why are they're Nazis at this?
Your,
your,
your rally peterson.
But there were no Nazis at the Raleigh.
Um,
but that kind of thing just get getting
repeated over and over.
And that's a kind of character
assassination attempts.
So we're here with the man who've
survived one character assassination
attempt.
Um,
then there are threats of shaming to
create a chill in classrooms campus in
society at large.
And you know,
that's part of the reason I'm here today
because I have seen things written by
students that they feel they cannot even
at my blessings university discuss many
diff,
many important subjects.
One of those letters was actually
published in the varsity about a student
who was in a bioethics class and they
were discussing sexuality and they even
discussed aspects of Chen transgendered.
And he wanted us to do a paper on it and
is very thoughtful.
A decent professor basically just
dissuaded him.
So there are things that we're not
allowed to,
to talk about or think about.
Now privilege,
privilege is used to say the people who
are not from a protected group,
which is often put into legislation or
in the popular mind,
are not entitled to speak on certain
issues,
certain key issues.
So privilege limits who can speak and
it's based on the assumption that people
from what is designated as a non,
sorry,
as a,
as a non vulnerable group carry a kind
of original sin based on the group that
they come from.
It's usually buttressed by a narrative
stating that the person's ancestors did
terrible things and had life easy.
Hence the privilege.
By the way,
the word privilege also was used by my,
by the early communists to describe the
bourgeois.
And in the early parts of the revolution
it was sufficient to be bourgeois,
to be rounded up and shot because you
had privilege.
And of course many people,
many thoughtful people are scratching
their heads because they find it hard to
distinguish this kind of categorization
from bigotry since it bree prejudges
people by the group they come from,
okay.
One of the politically correct methods
that's evolving is what I call
asymmetrical lawfare.
So asymmetrical lawfare is writing law
or legal code or institutional code to
give an advantage to an accuser who
would shut down the free expression of
others.
And how do we do this?
Well,
we reexamined evidentiary criteria and
you know what counts for some kind of
elicit act or problematic activity.
So if you can't prove aggression alleged
new category,
micro aggression,
this involves defining hate,
speech,
discrimination and harassment down.
In other words,
lowering the threshold of each of these.
These things are important things.
Okay,
the definitions are,
or sliding and changing.
If you can't improve mal intention or
any intention,
say the harm is done unintentionally and
that can be every bit as much a human
rights violation.
And then you define words up.
So words become action and a critical
word
becomes violence.
Now his speech violence is speech
action.
Well,
you know at times speech is action.
The philosopher Jl Austin,
and how to do things with words pointed
out that language can have what he
called the performative aspect.
So when a bride or groom says,
I do,
or a general says attack,
the speaker is doing something with
words that has a legal consequence.
But does the fact that some words can be
given a legal context sometimes mean
that all words we disagree with it
should be seen as violent actions.
That is the question.
Now these are pc values,
inclusiveness,
tolerance,
anti prejudice,
diversity,
openness to difference,
kindness and compassion,
living together,
nonjudgmental ism,
transparent transparency.
And increasingly one hears people
talking the language of seeking a
therapeutic culture where we create a
world where everyone feels good and
their feelings are valued and respected.
That is the PC understanding of a
therapeutic culture.
Um,
you know,
if you look at these,
I think it's pretty clear that many
Canadians support these values.
I think it's also clear that these are
placeholders that many people defined
somewhat differently.
And when it gets down to the nitty
gritty,
and you said something like diversity,
but what exactly do you mean by that?
But these words have a great plastic
power,
not neuroplastic,
but just plastic.
You know,
in the sense that they're very evocative
and there's a little lot of quote,
forgive the,
the dirty word,
buy in,
um,
to these words if you just use these
words and don't think through how to use
them.
And the other thing about them is
they're all about justice and equality.
They're all about good things.
So why the utterly intolerant behavior?
If these are your goals,
is it simply a case of weakness of will
people who are pc care for these values?
But like many of the rest of us,
they fail to live up to their values.
Why intolerant?
Is that a case of projection?
Unable to be tolerant,
kind,
and open as much as they would sincerely
wish to be?
Do they have a guilty conscience and to
deal with that,
that the then project their faults on to
others righteously condemn them feeling
themselves pure of heart.
There was a lot of projection,
by the way,
in the little video I showed you,
remember when wipe that smirk off your
face?
Did you see that smirk?
I could.
Could not see that smirk.
Um,
but it must have been fun to give him
the gears.
Um,
now remember when you project one of
your faults onto another person,
you become blind to it and yourself.
That's the purpose of projection.
Yeah.
Again,
why the non-compassionate noninclusive
intolerant behavior or social justice
warriors?
Simply opportunists using these commonly
shared values that I showed you as the
ideal tools,
the ideal hammers to attack those
they're competing with for political
power.
Remember,
these values of inclusion are shared by
many of us.
That's why being accused of being racist
or sexist or something very much stings
and anyone with a good conscience,
anyone with a conscience is very,
it's a quickly frozen by such an
accusation.
Interestingly,
those who don't have much of a
conscience or not frozen by such an
accusation,
but as the accusations are repeated over
and over and over,
they begin to lose their potency,
which is a problem because there is such
a thing as racism.
It's sort of like a government that just
printing more and more money.
Soon your dollar doesn't do anything.
And then there's this question
considering how inclusive and Koombaya
these values are.
Why does social justice warriors call
themselves warriors?
They're not peacemakers,
for instance.
So let's turn now to the classic
articulation of freedom of speech.
Um,
this is not the only stream.
There are judicial streams,
et Cetera,
but I actually prefer the philosophical
stream to the judicial stream.
So this is John Stuart mill who wrote on
liberty in 1859 and he prefaced the book
with a quote of a sentence from another
book,
but this sentence very much sums up much
of it on liberty is about,
so it's from the Greatville home,
a von Humbolt,
the grand leading principal towards
which every argument unfolded in these
pages directly converges is the absolute
and essential importance of human
development in its richest diversity.
It's almost as though it might have been
written by a certain kind of
psychologist,
but it's about human flourishing and
thriving and somehow or other liberty is
about that in a very big way.
Now,
he makes clear in the book that there's
a fundamental opposition between
individual liberty and tyranny.
They're fundamentally opposed as liberty
increases,
authoritarianism decreases,
and vice versa.
Your meal did get involved in political,
the politics of his day.
He wrote the subject of women,
one of the first,
uh,
feminist books he wrote on Uti,
uti on utilitarianism.
He wrote on liberty with his wife
Harriet Taylor,
who very much influenced the book and
who passed away before it was published.
I mean,
most of the book was obviously his,
but um,
he learned a lot from her.
He worked to extend the vote and he was
one of the best educated people in the
19th century.
He learned ancient Greek at the age of
three and his autobiography is famous
for these kinds of things.
So whenever somebody wants to limit free
speech,
the first thing out of their mouth is I
love free speech Bot or we believe in
free speech bought free speech,
always has limits and mel would agree
with that.
The difference is the railroad has
booked to create a space for free speech
that would be reasonable.
And often when people are limiting it,
they're trying to move in the other
direction.
So let's look at one of the many ways he
articulated this.
No one it actions should be as free as
opinions.
On the contrary,
even opinions lose their immunity when
the circumstances in which they're
expressed are such as to constitute
their expression,
a positive instigation to some ms gvs
act.
And then he gives examples like a
positive instigation of a ms gvs act
would be the following.
There are a lot of poor people and the
corn growers have stopped growing corn
to protect prices.
They assemble around the home of the
corn grower and then you speak to them
and yell and talk about how the corn
growers are starving to death.
That would be seen as incitement to an
angry group of people that's becoming a
mob and could immediately lead to
violence.
So the threshold is fairly high there.
But also notice he says no one pretends
that action should be as free as
opinions.
It's very clear in his mind that actions
are not opinions and opinions are not
actions.
Words are not actions.
They have to be distinguished.
If we are to get this space that
President Obama says we need.
Okay.
Freedom of speech for mill is not just a
right.
Okay?
It is a necessity.
It is a necessity for the functioning of
a democracy.
It is the oil that makes or the fuel
that makes the engine grow and for the
healthy functioning of the individual.
Why?
Because human history is filled with
error,
error.
Coming from authority,
from faith,
from religion,
from political claims,
from science,
from ideologues,
augury prophecy and from common sense.
Okay,
so this error must be examined and I
don't have to list all the scientific
areas we've made over the years and I
can list a few we're making right now,
but this is not the time for it.
Free speech and inquiry are our best
chance to overcome our extraordinary all
human,
all too human proclivity for error.
Now it's important to understand how
freedom and then how freedom of speech
emerges.
And in a few elegant paragraphs,
mills just lays this out.
For most of human history,
humanity has lived under tyranny or
authoritarian rule,
and if you think of the map I just
showed you,
we're pretty close to that today as
well.
Authoritarian regimes are run by the few
whose who see their subjects as their
belongings,
their chattel,
and they use violence against them when
they please take their property as they
wish and prosecute and punish them at
will.
The law in this situation is as it has,
as Sadam Hussein said,
the law is the two lines above my
signature.
Now,
why is free speech so frightening to the
tire?
And he has a lot of power.
It he rules through fear.
And so he never really knows who he can
trust.
And that can include some of his
generals.
The tyrant and his crew are ultimately a
minority and the people are many.
And so it's important for the tyrant,
but the people are not allowed to
publicly share the extent to which they
suffer under his rule because then they
might organize against him.
The tyrant,
the emperor,
the dictator,
and the odds are in their favor.
So if you think about the story of the
emperor's new clothes,
it's even pinker has argued when that
child speaks out and tells the truth in
that story and says the emperor is
naked.
It's not that the adults have not seen
that he is naked as individuals,
they have seen it.
But when the little boy ix speaks up in
the crowd,
now everyone knows that everyone knows.
So emperors and tyrants create an
atmosphere of fear to silence people and
stop them from talking about things that
really everybody knows.
Okay.
Now when the first democracy developed,
something happened to the relationship
between the people and their rulers.
It was reversed.
The people no longer worked for or were
owned by the government,
but the government worked for B,
the people.
These are John Locke's ideas,
very liberating ideas.
Power is now with the people,
a large group and they only lend it via
elections to some few of their number to
rule them temporarily.
And because of the people choose their
rulers in elections,
they came to see themselves as both free
and self governing and self governing.
People being a large group require free
speech to deliberate about their
options,
the laws,
the war,
peace who will represent them and so on.
Yeah,
and free speech therefore involves
challenging ideas about what we should
do as a community and it's essential
that they're challenged over and over
again to learn the strengths and
weaknesses of these monumental decisions
that we make.
This can only be done in dialogue where
credit,
uh,
no criticisms are off limits,
but elective officials with authority or
other vested interests are always
tempted to limit the discussion.
Of course.
The other thing I should say is that the
liberal education,
which is what universities are,
are supposed to be offering,
was originally thought to be an
education in liberty.
Self governing.
People need to be educated in some way
in the craft of leadership.
And the liberal education meant
familiarizing yourself with some of the
core texts that helped people to become
free so that they can understand that.
Yeah,
there's not a lot of that going on.
Even at great universities.
It's kind of like a boutique niche study
at this point,
but that's why they were called the
liberal arts and education to liberty.
Now,
this is very important for us today.
Democracies aren't perfect.
Um,
we can be a great friend of democracy,
but the greatest of friends does not
flatter his friend.
Nil observed that in democracies,
even though the people rule,
there can still be threats to free
speech and liberty.
This is because strictly speaking in
democracy,
not all people rule at any one time.
Rather the majority rules and the
majority holds sway not just over
government,
but over large sectors of public
opinion.
As Tocqueville,
Alexis de Tocqueville observed in
democracy,
a tyranny of the majority can always
arise in which the many can suppress the
few,
the majority inflated by their power,
their sense of self certainty,
their sense of legitimacy brought about
by their greater number of their bulk
can begin to act with a reckless
confidence and indifference to others,
perhaps not unlike an absolute prince.
So following Tocqueville mill paid much
attention to the fact that custom and
public opinion in common ideas can also
tyrannized over people.
And that in fact,
often in our everyday life,
these customs and these opinions can be
actually more problematic than even
government and laws because it can put
limits on liberty of those who think and
act differently from the rest.
And it can do,
do it by all measure.
All I'll all different means shaming
ostracism and sober so that you can ruin
a life with these things.
Okay,
so why do I say that?
Freedom of speech,
especially in it's,
it's essential for all of us.
We can't function without it in a
democracy.
But why is it especially important for,
for people who were from minorities and
marginalized groups,
people who carry minority opinions?
I'm sure many of you carry minority
opinions in some areas it's this one
person can't out vote 100 and minority
can never vote a majority,
but one person or a minority with a
superior argument can publish,
write and speak to a hundred or a
thousand or 10,000 or a million people.
And that gives them a chance.
That's why it's falling for members of
smaller groups to undermine freedom of
speech.
Absolute folly.
Yeah.
Now what about the psychology of the
person who's doing the undermining here?
Mill says,
introduces a theme to deny others for
speech is to presume oneself fallible.
A person,
they say,
I'm denying you speech because you make
me feel,
because what you do will lead to
violence,
but they're presuming it will lead to
violence.
They have to show it or prove it.
So here's what mel says,
the opinion which is attempted to
suppress by authority,
they possibly be true.
Those who desire to suppress it,
of course deny its truth,
but they are not infallible.
They have no authority to decide the
question for all mankind and exclude
every other person from the means of
judging.
Now I submit to you that is a very
democratic sentiment.
It's respectful of other people.
Yeah.
He goes on about those who silence
others to refuse a hearing to an opinion
because they are sure that is,
it is false,
is to assume that their certainty is
absolutely is the same thing as absolute
certainty.
All silencing of discussion is an
assumption of infallibility.
Okay.
You know,
I find it so interesting that as the
forced speech debate has developed that
in the public domain,
there have been so few lawyers speaking
up for free speech.
I can tell you that 25 years ago it
would not have been the case.
Um,
it's also interesting that you know,
our finest text,
our most comprehensive text I would say
on liberty is written not by a lawyer,
someone who loves order and seeks rules
for ordering things,
but by a philosopher,
a man who knows that it's,
it is often hard to know things for
certain.
And who likes socrates,
who influenced this book sometimes sees
that his greatest asset is knowing that
he doesn't know.
This is the wisdom of acknowledging our
ignorance when we have it.
In such wisdom has the effect of
moderating us by creating intellectual
humility which can actually help people
get along
okay.
Again,
and this is really,
really important.
You don't know your side if you don't
know their side.
Quote mill,
he who knows only his own side of the
case knows little of that.
His reasons may be good and no one may
have been able to refute them,
but if he has equally unable to refute
the reasons on the opposite side,
if he does not so much as know what they
are,
he has no grounds for preferring either
opinion.
Tell that to your favorite.
No at all.
Okay.
This may be one of the two or three most
important points I'm going to make
today.
If government wants to take away the
speech of someone you dislike or force
people to say things and you agree with
it,
it's worse to go along when you agree
with it.
Okay.
Mill,
let us suppose.
Therefore that the government is
entirely at one with the people and
never thinks of exerting any power of
coercion unless in agreement with what
it conceives to be their voice.
But I deny the right of the people to
exercise such coersion either by
themselves or by their government.
The power itself,
is it legitimate?
The best government has no more title to
it than the worst.
It is as noxious or more noxious when
exerted in accordance with public
opinion.
Then when in opposition to it,
and I think it's more noxious.
So this is why you shouldn't agree to be
forced to do what you believe in.
It's even more noxious to give
government power when it's doing so as
an accord with public opinion or yours
because the coercion is sweetened.
And that way can develop without
opposition in this short sided way,
we and feeble our chief protection
against tyranny,
he liberty.
Now I want to switch to a different
ground and I'm going to talk about um,
three different approaches to the
infallible mind,
the divided brain.
So it's a bit of a neuroscientific,
take some things on psychological
development and then something called
the inability to mentalize,
which is a series of clinical
observations.
So this is our brain and it's divided
and it's divided for a reason.
A lot of people know it's divided,
but don't think about the reason our
spleen doesn't seem to be divided,
not every organ.
Our stomach is not divided in this way.
Not Every Oregon appears to be
symmetrical and divided
and the divided brain isn't about
language being on one side and
creativity on the other.
That was a simplification that came out
of the 60s there's little bits of truth
to it,
but it's far too simplified.
But there are actually some very,
very significant differences between the
two sides of the brain.
And the person who put this together is
doctor Ian mcgilchrist.
He's a psychiatrist and he's an
outstanding intellect.
If he was a great student of literature
as well,
and this is his book,
the master and his emissary.
Okay.
Now if you look at the,
this is looking at the brain from below,
so you don't usually do that.
I understand.
But if you were underneath the brain and
you looked at it very carefully,
in fact,
you would find that it's broader at the
right on the front and brought her on
the back of the left.
So you know it's only very grossly that
it looks like the two hemispheres are
and inside the connections are also
quite different.
So for instance,
the length of the connections between
cells in the right hemisphere is much
longer and it goes deep into the
emotional parts of the brain and reads a
lot of what's going on in the body.
And the left brain connections are
short.
It's like they're all talking to each
other.
Now,
one of the ways to get at
the very broad difference between the
left hemisphere and the right sometimes
called the left brain and the right,
imagine a bird pecking for seeds among
these stones and grit.
So to eat,
it's got to focus very narrowly on the
little seed and pick it out against the
background grid narrow focus.
But it also has to keep a wide focus and
keep on the lookout for new dangerous or
opportunities that might come on the
scene like predators,
potential mates,
or other food sources.
So this is more like reality.
One of those birds is pecking,
but it's also aware that there's another
comrade bird nearby.
How does it do that?
The narrow focus and the wide focus are
actually handled by different
hemispheres of the brain.
Now this is something very neat about a
bird's brain.
It's wired so that let's say the right
eye is completely processed by the left
hemisphere.
So human beings aren't quite like that.
So everything that comes in the window
or the right eye is processed in the
left hemisphere.
So the left hemisphere does all of that
narrow focus work to identify the little
bits of seed.
You're going to have to trust me,
this is going to be relevant to
political correctness.
It focuses on something.
It already knows this I've important.
So this is a big thing about the left
hemisphere.
It focuses on what it already knows is
important.
Seeds
and the right hemisphere.
It takes the world in as a whole.
So it's window to the world is the birds
left eye.
So it's vigilantly,
vigilantly searching for novelty,
what's not already know a Predator her
perhaps a new me.
It's looking for something new that
might be of importance,
but who knows what that would be.
So the right hemispheres,
attention is open minded and broadminded
because it doesn't quite know what it's
looking for and these things are going
on at the same time through different
eyes and different hemispheres.
It's not just switching back and forth.
Okay,
that's a bird.
What about humans?
Our eyes are wired slightly differently,
but the right hemisphere in humans is
astoundingly similar.
It sees holistically.
So before things are digested into
parts,
it takes in the whole,
it seeks novelty.
It seeks out the unknown,
a new information.
And because it's holistic,
it sees everything in context.
It has a sustained broad,
open alertness.
It sees relationships.
That's about context and very important
for our discussion today.
It sees individuals.
It sees if you,
if you discover a human being and you
see them as a unique individual in their
wholeness,
not in their parts,
but how they all come together.
That is a right brain function.
It is not abstract at all.
When you meet someone else who have you
never met for the first time,
it's a unique experience.
You're not generalizing from it yet.
It is the seat of empathy.
It's where we learn to read facial
expressions and the emotions of others
and our own emotions and because it sees
context,
it sees humor lighten up.
It understands metaphor.
It perceives emotional subtlety and
nuance
and the left hemisphere in humans
narrow,
sharply focused attention to detail.
It is actually tasked by the right
hemisphere when something new and
important is perceived to begin to map
it in fine detail and then it's maps
produced isolated parts more than
relationships or context.
Think of that book drawing on the right
side of the brain.
If you've ever taken that course and
you'll understand what I'm talking
about.
It identifies things by abstract labels,
not context,
and it works with categories of people,
categories,
not individuals.
So whenever people are over generalizing
about people,
it has a left hemisphere flavor.
Language is interpreted differently on
the left and the right.
It's interpreted literally it's
humorless because there's no sense of
context.
It's abstract.
It rest things from their context.
Context.
Abstract is from the Latin draw away,
so what do I need?
Okay,
how did the things that the left
hemisphere does when it makes this map
of the world is it confuses the map with
the world.
We've all heard this,
don't confuse the map with the
territory.
That's a really good left hemisphere
thing to do.
Now,
where is all of this data coming from?
It's coming from hundreds and hundreds
of studies of patients with strokes who
lose Maine,
right hemisphere function or left
hemisphere is function.
Or we can use certain kinds of magnetic
devices and apply it to the brain and
shut down parts of the brain and see
what the remaining hemisphere is like
and then give them all sorts of
cognitive tests and we can actually
inject anesthetic into certain arteries
and shut down a whole hemisphere of the
brain.
So there's many,
many ways that really thousands and
thousands of scientists have have gotten
at this.
So the map is felt,
so when people have certain kinds of
left hemispheric strokes,
sorry,
when they have certain kinds of right
hemispheric strokes and they're left
just with the left hemisphere,
we can see how concrete people are about
maps.
No,
the problem is with good map is as good
as it is,
is the world is always changing and maps
become quickly out of date.
There's a few that may not come out of,
you know,
go out of date quickly.
Like gravity seems to be what it's
always been.
But the left hemisphere is kind of like
that person who when lost in,
you know,
on a,
on a car ride says to his spouse,
we can't be lost.
It's right here on the map.
We're in the right place and he says it
over and over again even though they're
not.
So it's got to kind of know it all.
Listen,
a flavor of infallibility,
if you will.
Let me give you an example of
a literal versus non literal
interpretation.
Imagine I was visiting your home and I
started to breakout in a sweat and I
said,
you know,
it must be 90 degrees in here.
Now a literal interpretation would be
norman has made a statement,
a meteor,
a logical statement about the
temperature.
A non literal interpretation would be
normally,
would you like me to open the window?
Now
that statement takes into account the
context of my statement.
It's relationship to me,
the speaker,
and to the overall environment.
It requires indirect interpretation and
empathy.
And these are right hemispheric
attributes.
So here they are,
the difference on the left,
isolated,
no contacts,
no relationships,
sees categories,
abstraction generalization tends to
infallibility.
Rigid maps are the reality.
And I would suggest to you when there's
bigotry,
it's coming out of this kind of move
plus many other things,
it theology,
emotion,
et Cetera.
But from a cognitive point,
this is
part of it and the right is holistic.
It's sees individuals at once.
New Information.
Okay,
I'm going to link some of that up
loosely with some things about
developmental psychology that are
relevant for political correctness.
I'll tie it together.
This is John Paij.
Um,
probably the greatest developmental
psychologist who ever lived and one of
the things he tried to do is describe
norm,
normal cognitive development.
And he got a lot of it right.
A lot of it holds up very well.
Even cross culturally,
there are some things,
and I'm into the plastic brain as you
know,
that can happen slightly differently in
other places,
but he made very,
very broad observations after years and
years of very fine detailed work.
So here's some things he found out.
There's an early cognitive stage from
two to seven where children don't
understand the logic and they have a lot
of magical thinking.
They have a limited sense that they have
a mind that is perceiving the world from
their tick,
from particular point of view.
In fact,
some of them probably don't have any
sense of that.
And I'll go into that.
And then there's this thing called
centrism.
They can only focus on one aspect of a
situation at a time.
Okay.
And this is related to egocentrism,
which is a kind of,
where do I fit in the world?
Um,
sort of concept.
It's not just about selfishness during
this stage.
Their communication and thoughts are
generally about themselves,
somewhat limited ability to see
situations from another's point of view.
They tend to assume that others see the
world is they do.
And some people can remain egocentric
all their lives.
Um,
and many,
if not all of us can under great
emotional pressure or physical illness,
regress and show signs of egocentrism
that we normally don't.
Now,
why are children egocentric?
Well,
there's a number of reasons for this,
but one very simple reason that's hard
to get out of your head once you get it
in your head is this,
children at this age are quite
cognitively focused on the external
physical world,
which can be observed and what they can
observe of the social world.
But our internal mental states are not
directly observable period.
So the young child really has a concept
of mental states or the mind.
This means there's a kind of mind
blindness,
limited awareness that other people have
minds and more importantly there is a
limited awareness that they themselves
have an invisible mine that is
interpreting reality and each of you try
to remember that moment in your life
if you can.
When you realized,
actually this is me processing all of
this.
I remember I was in nursery school and I
was looking at what if no,
no divinity spoke to me at the time that
I'm aware of.
I was looking at some sticks and I was
just right and I realized I'm looking at
those sticks and other people aren't
seeing those sticks and some or other.
It's self consciousness,
self awareness and the awareness that I
had in mind and that therefore other
people had mines crystallized at that
moment for me and each of you probably
had that experience.
Did they?
Do any of you remember that?
Now what happens if you're not aware
that you have a mind that's processing
everything?
Your subjective experience of events
seems like the only reality.
You are not aware that your experience
is just your take on events,
that it might be a misinterpretation,
a false belief,
or a product of your experience.
Interpretations are often centered on
the self.
Think the child whose parents are
getting divorced,
who thinks it's my fault,
it must be my fault.
That's egocentrism.
Now we gradually grow out of it.
The next stage from seven to 11 shows
the beginning of new brain maturation.
The child begins to use inductive logic
becomes,
becomes aware of the existence of other
minds.
And this can often happen when they
realize that you can fool people,
that people can have false beliefs.
And so piaget did experiments on this,
but for there to be a false belief means
that there's gotta be an internal mental
process in the person who has the false
belief that can be misled or mistaken is
somehow different,
is processing events.
And then development proceeds and
abstract reasoning kicks in.
Children can think logically and
language.
They don't take everything literally,
and children always love stories,
but at this,
at this point in time,
they can begin to analyze the literature
and get much more deeply into the minds
of the characters
so they're mentally rising.
The ability to appreciate the one has a
mind that interprets reality and that
other people have such a mind
when you mentally as well,
you don't even know you're doing it.
It's automatic.
It's unconscious.
We realize too that we make inferences
about reality all the time and are prone
to error.
We realize that the mental states of
other people change rapidly and the only
sensible way to know what their feeling
is to inquire or to take a curious
stance.
If Socrates was the smartest man in
ancient Greece,
why did he spend all of his time talking
to other people were who were his
arguably has inferiors much of the time
it's because there's something moe toric
about thinking and learning and that's
why dialogue is a very important thing.
So you can say,
you know,
I'd be pretty good in a totalitarian
regime.
I'm very independently minded.
I would just keep my mouth shut.
And if there was no freedom of speech,
I'd never expressed myself.
And that might work.
And also you might get very,
very sick.
You might get sick because it might be
that if thinking is so important to you
than expressing it and interacting with
people about it might just be the thing
you need.
The way,
you know,
some of us need to breathe air.
So
when we mentally as well,
we can focus on others.
We can form stable relationships.
This is all the opposite of the
infallible frame of mind.
Now,
I want to talk about the absence of
mentalization in adults,
not in kids.
There are many situations where we lose
awareness that we have a mind
interpreting reality.
As I said,
high states of stress and emotion.
And some people never develop the
ability to mentalize in the first place.
And some have mental illnesses that make
it hard to mentalize,
um,
or to think or imagine if you're trapped
in a very intense delusion,
um,
you are probably not mental ising.
Um,
one of the things we've learned about
men,
we've learned a lot about mentalizing
it's absence by studying the autistic
spectrum.
And for a number of autistic children,
it's very,
very difficult.
It could be very high on the spectrum
and have difficulty reading,
um,
emotions and mentalizing other minds.
In fact,
the term mind blindness came out of the
literature on autism.
And children with autism are teased
mercilessly as,
as you know,
it's awful.
And imagine what it's like for them not
being able to understand other minds
when kids are teasing them,
when they miss things.
And then they will also misinterpret
teasing or things that were,
were very gentle remarks.
Not to meant to,
um,
to tease the child if you can't mentally
wise.
So it,
it's,
it's a terrible trap.
There's another thing that happens,
which where people arguably can
mentalize but they don't.
And that's in extreme forms of
narcissism.
So what the narcissist pers does,
and it's just imagine,
uh,
imagine I'm a big narcissist.
Um,
what I do is,
and I'm dealing with,
with you,
uh,
I take all of my negative qualities and
I attribute to,
to them,
to you rather,
I keep all my,
my good qualities.
So now I'm very pure,
but I don't stop there.
Then I plagiarize all your special
qualities and ti think their mine.
So if you're in a meeting with a
narcissist,
you come up with a great idea.
He says,
what a great meeting.
I can't believe I came up with that
idea.
You know?
So imagine you're in a knowledge culture
or in a situation where knowledge is
important or an ethnic group or
knowledge is important and you can get a
lot of narcissistic,
know what all of them going on,
right?
Um,
people who never formed close,
secure attachments with others to help
them read their feelings
will have difficulty.
Mentalizing and there's a lot of
psychiatric conditions where people have
grown up.
Without that input,
there was nothing malign.
The parents may have had difficulty
reading emotions,
but then the child has difficulty
reading emotions and difficulty
mentalizing.
But you can see there's just many
different causes of metalizing and
about,
so I've said that in autism there's
often a lot of right hemisphere damage
that helps to explain some of the mental
ising problems.
But you know,
in very high trauma in Ptsd for
instance,
we now know that the right hemisphere
parts of it actually go offline.
They stopped processing.
And remember,
that's the hemisphere that helps you pay
attention to novelty.
So you're stuck in a trauma,
you're reliving it over and over again.
You're in a new situation,
but you can't even notice the new
situation and a lot of your feelings and
your cognition is cut down and you can't
even read emotion properly.
We need to be able to read emotion to
read minds.
When we can't,
mental wise,
our mental reality becomes the outer
reality.
They're equivalent,
they're isomorphic.
Our internal world has all the power of
the external world and all our thoughts
feel real and as vivid as intense
sensory experience.
We can be terrified by our own mental
experience.
Therefore it's so vivid and we lack the
normal ways of reassuring ourselves such
as saying,
I'm just imagining this or it might not
happen.
That doesn't happen.
It's all real.
So our negative thoughts about ourselves
and others feel totally unalterable.
They're set in concrete and remember,
you don't have to be mentally ill to
experience this kind of thing.
Any of us can slip into my mentalizing
in extreme situations and we become mind
blind.
How does that play out though?
We become intolerant of alternative
perspectives.
We are humorless.
We are predisposed to massive
generalizations and speak in absolute
terms.
Men are always,
women are always,
we understand language literally and
often misunderstand nuance and so we
tend to misinterpret others.
This is important because we can't read
them.
We see them as malevolent and we start
blaming and fault finding and we get
angry.
There's rigidity and external focus.
When you don't have an internal life,
we're prone to all or nothing thinking
our thought processes rigidified we
stick to the first explanation that
occurs to us.
Thinking about all the arguments,
you know,
where someone makes it silly first
explanation and then they dig into it.
So there's a tendency to rigid quasi and
fallibility and little awareness of how
our behavior is impacting others.
We're not mentalizing.
This is really important now,
unable to perceive our internal states
as internal.
We focused on externals for just school,
government,
the job,
the neighbor and what others say.
And this causes a great problem for us.
We become thin skin because when we're
over focused on externals and what
others say,
and we're unable to step back and
reflect our self esteem regulation,
it comes a prisoner of what others
think.
When we don't mentalize,
we become hyper responsive to the,
even the most benign criticism.
We are trapped in what we perceive as
their point of view about us.
And critical words or disagreement can
feel like violence because we're so
sensitive.
And that's why people say you're
validating my existence.
So to summarize this psychological brain
material for things contribute to moving
towards a state where we don't learn or
recognize our points of other points of
view and tend to wear the infallible
frame of mind regression to earlier
states of functioning under pressure or
reliance on left brain categorization,
generalization,
taking things out of context,
and I can tell you I could teach a
person to become left brained.
I can take any number of ideologies and
train them to become left brained and
turn off their right brain functioning.
Then we can have mind blindness for a
variety of causes.
And as a reminder,
George Elliot showed anger makes us feel
divine justice is on our side,
so all the wisdom of the gods is with us
when we are angry.
Now this is the final section of my talk
and these are ancient insights into
justice and anger.
Okay?
As we've said,
political correctness is focused on
justice and compassion.
The ancient philosophers,
Plato,
aristotle,
Socrates,
Xena,
Fon,
Seneca,
and so on.
Thought a lot about justice,
but they didn't often speak about
justice in an of itself.
They saw it as one of four cardinal
virtues.
And the word for virtue in Greek is
Eritay and that means excellence.
So it's something you cultivate.
It's an excellent you cultivate.
So the and the four cardinal virtues,
when you look at how they talked about
them,
we're often described,
um,
are seen as interdependent.
Cardinal comes from the Latin carto and
it means that on which something turns
or depends like a hinge.
And the idea is that a good life for the
individual and the community depends on
cultivating these virtues and you have
to do all of them.
What are they?
Justice,
wisdom,
moderation and courage and virtue.
Definition of a virtue.
It's a way of behaving that's conducive
to happiness over time,
they have to be cultivated and they have
to be practiced.
Virtues or way of vices are ways of
behaving that are conducive to
unhappiness and they're also practiced.
Now know this is an important point.
Compassion was not thought to be a
virtue.
It's only fairly recently in some
respects that compassion was thought,
has become a virtue for the ancients.
Compassion was a feeling,
something available immediately.
Almost anyone.
To a child that's,
it wasn't something that was cultivated.
It was part of the raw material of being
a human being.
I'm aware that there are eastern
practices or compassion meditations
they're in the east.
Compassion was something that was
treated like a virtue,
so here's justice.
Justice is a good thing,
so it's understood.
It's a virtue till would seem the more
justice we have,
the better,
the more the merrier.
And this indeed is the assumption of
most social justice activism.
How can you have too much of a good
thing?
The ancients were interested in balance
and they saw that the virtues do not
stand each alone and in fact by
themselves they can actually in
sometimes even be problematic.
They observed that the practice of
justice for instance,
without wisdom or moderation often led
to terrible consequences.
Even in there in the democracies.
It's a painful truth.
History's greatest crimes have been con
emitted in the name of justice
in the name of justice,
the Spanish inquisition and name of
justice taking this man and anabaptists
and burning him alive for Harrison in
the name of rights are treasured human
rights.
The name of the rights of man,
the French revolutions,
Raine of terror,
and this isis,
it's all about justice according to
them.
So for the Greeks,
justice by itself could spin out of
control and moderation was needed.
This is a picture of Delphi where
our ancient writings tell us nothing in
excess was inscribed.
So moderation is needed for justice
because justice is so closely related in
practice to the wish to punish.
It can be harsh,
it can be vengeful.
Even those of Us Nice people who
restrain ourselves from unjust acts
often feel a strong resentment towards
lawbreakers and wished to get even we
say he got away with it kind of implying
we would've liked to have done it,
but we held back the wish to punish is
the wish to hurt.
And Socrates points this out in several
dialogues very effectively.
So justice must be tempered
and it's tempered by moderation and
wisdom.
And the Bible would argue by mercy
[inaudible].
Okay,
this is a side of it.
Justice can become suddenly harsh in
groups.
And Freud pointed out that people in
groups can readily regress and express
terrible hostility.
One of the things he said in group
psychology and the analysis of the ego
was in groups.
People delegate their conscience to
their chosen leader of the time.
And if the leader sanctions,
aggression,
suddenly civilized people can rapidly
become unbounded by conscience.
And you can see the extraordinary
aggression that can be lurking.
I think of antisemitism in the Middle
Ages.
It wasn't just the sinners who sanctions
setting Jewish homes,
synagogues and people on fire,
but the saints.
And once a sate says kill,
there's little stopping the crowd from
becoming cruel because in a way their
conscience is permitting it.
Yeah,
you just saw private junk Justice
Simpson style.
Private justice is relevant today.
Um,
because of changes I think in the
various tribunals and legal codes,
um,
that we're seeing.
Um,
what's you're privileging subjectivity?
private justice can escalate false
claims.
One key reason historically for having
public justice,
uh,
public justice system was to put an end
to private feuds and revenge bloodbaths
when people took justice in their own
hands.
Of course the original justice was
people doing justice in their own hands.
So private fuse of course are driven by
each party.
Subjective sense.
They're offended and they're non
systematic interpretation of events and
public justice at its best.
Attempts to use more objective
evidentiary criteria then private
justice.
But the PC justice tribunals by
reintroducing the subjective sense of
grievance,
the Professor Peterson is spoken about
as a criterion for human rights
violations.
Actually I would argue returns us to the
perils of private justice.
But now with public approval and public
and procure,
nope.
Why is wisdom necessary?
Wouldn't it be nice if those kids who
are shutting everyone down actually went
to university and said,
I'd like to be wise,
it would actually help their cause.
Because if you are not wise,
you really cannot know what is right and
wrong.
And you may think you'd,
it's an easy thing to tell all the time.
But there's so many disputes about
justice through the world.
They clearly people are having trouble
sorting that out.
And in Plato's Republic,
which is also called on the just,
he begins it,
um,
with socrates asking people to define
justice.
People are demanding it.
Say,
okay,
tell me what you want.
And none of them can define it.
They all fall apart.
I can't talk about it here today,
but that's the brilliant beginning of
Plato's.
And ultimately he shows us the justice
requires balance,
the entire personality and in the city.
Uh,
and it relates to moderation and wisdom
and courage.
Now,
why courage?
Yeah.
Without courage,
you can't stand up for what is just,
and not everyone agrees on what outcome
is.
Just still,
there is a fight.
And entering that fight requires grit
and it entails risk.
You know,
I asked you to think of all the
university administrators of our day who
have caved in across North America and
let one lecture after another.
These shut down without a fight
betraying their mission,
their university mission and their
mission to their students.
Sometimes they agree with shutting these
things down,
but I think more often it's,
um,
a lack of courage a and careerism mixed
together.
But physical courage is not enough to
guarantee justice because you need
intellectual courage to have wisdom.
Wisdom requires the willingness to
undertake free inquiry and take apart
and examine your own soothing fictions
and beliefs.
Face,
human morality,
Morat mortality,
and your limits mill.
Who drew very much from socrates,
argued the free inquiry was the major
basis,
one of the major bases for freedom of
speech.
So ultimately the virtues are
independent.
Justice depends on courage,
moderation and wisdom and wisdom depends
on intellectual courage.
For the ancients,
politics is not the only way,
and at times not even the best way to
improve the world.
Their cultivation of your own virtue can
have a great impact on others.
What community would not be better off
with people who cultivate,
cultivate,
wisdom,
moderation,
courage and justice.
So I'm moving to a summation now.
These are our pc paradoxes.
These are our goals on the left.
And these are methods on the right.
Inclusiveness,
a goal method,
ostracism,
firing opponents,
Reza demanding resignations,
a goal we'll tolerance and diversity
method,
intolerance of diversity of opinion as
Obama noted,
openness method close to aspects of
traditional society and religion and
many other things,
kindness and compassion.
Yet they demand punishment of opponents,
even for unintentional discrimination,
firing people,
Internet shaming,
slander and character assassination,
living together.
Unfortunately now on us college
campuses,
there are a number of student groups who
want to segregate themselves by ethnic
group
being nonjudgmental and non prejudiced.
Yet using the idea of privilege to
condemn whole groups as guilty of an
original sin by their birth whole
group's called bigoted,
sexist,
violent and judgmental of themselves by
the way,
very judgmental of themselves,
not just others.
Finally,
transparency and yet the endorsement of
anonymous complaints.
Yeah,
history shows the higher,
the more Utopian the goal,
the easier it becomes to justify
Barbara's ends to get there.
The more unrealistic the goal,
the more likely the failure,
the greater the inpatients and the
greater the need for scapegoats.
The greatest evils in human history in
terms of innocence,
murdered Mao's cultural revolution,
the Soviet murder of its citizens,
the Holocaust were all done in the name
of justice.
You'll notice I haven't discussed it
theology because Professor Peterson's
going to talk about that.
And there are many,
many deep strands to enrich this
discussion when looking at the
narratives and what people are trying to
do.
But just in terms of the infallibility
question,
etiologies or belief systems based on
myth disguised as science or philosophy
that overly simplify our complex world
around one or two or several ideas.
And because they fail to account for its
complexity,
they tend to become doctrinaire and um,
posed as infallible and challenged.
There is even an idiot logic in etiology
seeking temperament.
Eric Hoffer who wrote the true believer
described a very interesting phenomenon,
which is during Hitler's rise to power,
when there were Nazis and communists on
the street and after the end of the
Second World War where there were still
Nazis about and communists in eastern
Europe,
people would often switch from being a
communist to a Nazi or a Nazi to a
communist,
even though super officially these were
very,
very different ideologies that
hated each other.
And one of the things that hoffer was
able to point out when he analyze these
people as they were fanatics and
fanatics were people who had a sense of
self,
which they completely detest it.
Yeah.
So to say they had low self esteem
doesn't quite capture how hostile and
angry they were to themselves.
And what the etiology did to them is it
didn't grow theirself.
They didn't want to grow that six self.
It obliterated theirself.
They wanted obliteration.
And there are other people that I've
seen over the years who show signs,
not have it a terrible negative self.
So much as not having a strong sense of
self at all.
And they can turn to ideology,
which gives them the structure they feel
they don't have internally.
And if they're not mentalizing it's a
very appealing.
Okay.
So some final words on fourth speech
that triggered us getting together and
talking to you today.
Um,
Professor Peterson pointed out that
there's a tangle of laws in Canada which
if taken together can be red
as allowing the government to an if in
effect forced people to say things they
don't believe.
And some people like to say,
oh,
that couldn't be possible or it didn't
happen.
And Professor Peterson got two letters
from uft.
Well,
lawyers letters basically saying,
you've got to change your position on
for speech.
In other words,
they read it the way he did and he
debated a professor of law who basically
said,
yes,
I,
it's possible that you could be called
before the tribunal if you don't go
along with saying words,
um,
that we think are now mandated.
And they headed the Ontario Human Rights
Commission when asked,
well,
is he in violation?
She repeated the law.
She didn't say,
oh no,
that couldn't happen here in Ontario.
And then the lawyers he consulted in
other sense.
So there's free speech and there is
forced speech.
This is our charter section to be grants
everyone freedom of thought,
belief,
opinion and expression.
Notice expression comes last.
The first part is false belief.
Opinion,
expression including freedom of the
press and other media of communication.
The rights are together because they're
connected.
Free expression is a necessity and
necessary condition for the free
formation of thought and belief in
anyone who wants to argue that
compelling a person to say things they
don't believe in is not a violation of
their freedom of thought.
Belief and opinion
seems to me very much stretching the
charter.
Okay.
It's a case of government and the
proponents of forced speech,
not trusting sufficiently in the
goodness of most Canadians and the fact
that they have diverse opinions and that
we can benefit as per president.
Obama said,
when opinions collide,
it is a lapse into the infallible state
of mind.
But isn't it just a matter of etiquette,
isn't it good manners?
Well,
it might be if government didn't bring
force into it,
when's the last time you were forced to
have good manners?
Government could command many things by
force,
but they cannot command respect even for
others with force and respect is,
I suggest,
and I suspect precisely what the people
involved in this controversy really
yearn for.
So I think it's actually quite amazing
that those who drafted this legislation
have not summoned the creativity to find
a solution to this problem that does not
travel on other rights.
But if you don't believe or don't agree
with anything I've said so far,
then I would say this.
Always think of the next government
breaking the taboo in forcing,
endorsing for speech,
creating a taste or tolerance for it.
Habituating people to it as a legitimate
tool of power is handing your opponents
a new tool,
a shiny new tool and governments change
and you will have taught your opponents
that one can use force and get away with
it.
And especially if you're represented
minority or marginal group,
and I bet you that many of us,
depending on how you dissect things out
can be seen as part of a minority or
marginal group.
It is far better to persuade people than
force them.
If you force the changes,
they'll only stay in place as long as
you are.
Your side holds government.
But if you persuade people,
they will be on your side.
Even when government changes,
forced speech is a robotic solution to a
problem that is best solved with two way
empathy and understanding.
And in the historical,
clinical and scientific literature,
I've read that studies people being
forced to say things in families,
in concentration camps,
in unusual political situations in that
literature,
which studies people who are not trusted
to be good enough to find their own way
and say what they think.
We see these people led into a kind of
hopeless apathy and despair.
It leads to a kind of abdication of
authenticity and even their moral
development.
So I said the political correctness
today
is indeed mutually exclusive with
freedom of speech.
There's a tragic irony that the PC
attack on free speech is that,
um,
the tragic irony of the attack on free
speech is that free speech is one of the
most durable protections minorities and
marginalized groups have ever had.
And the shutdown and invalidation
techniques undermine the very ideals
they purport to defend and are based on
the proponents claiming and infallible
state of mind about what is
compassionate,
good,
safe,
and effective
in this kind of solution.
Nobody wins.
Political,
moral and scientific progress,
as well as our individual health require
a community that has a place for verbal
argument that's not violence.
It's the sublimation of our differences
into a verbal form,
far less vicious than true violence.
So the very individuality that pc
proponents treasure derives from
liberty,
which itself must be protected from two
equally powerful human tendencies that
of authoritarianism and human,
no,
it all of Islam.
And I conclude my last slide with mills
wisdom and his principles that mankind
are not infallible.
That their truth,
for the most part,
are only half truths.
That unity of opinion,
unless resulting from the fullest and
freest comparison of opposite opinions
is not desirable.
And diversity is not an evil,
but a good until mankind are much more
capable than at present of recognizing
all sides of the truth,
our principals applicable to men's modes
of action,
not less than their opinions.
[inaudible].